[Applause]
james against butler drives gets inside
stops blocked by butler
rejected out of bounds with 4.2 left on
the shot clock
the right mindset by lebron james
turning the corner but good job by jim
james looking finds caruso caruso fakes
and stolen by butler
[Applause]
butler guarded by morris
shot clock at four butler drive stops up
top robinson puts up a three
that's good it's good duncan robinson
from downtown
and the heat back on top by two
well you watch butler and he just
runs and unfortunately for the lakers
caruso and caldwell pope run into each
other
giving him just enough looking back to
robinson
up top to butler butler pulls up got it
jimmy butler does it again and the heat
take a two-point
butler one-on-one with marquis morris
butler drives
falling away got it again jimmy butler
puts the heat he else
james and butler throwing haymakers at
each other butler drives
and he's fouled
and butler right now is exhausted with
46.7 remaining
he's got two free throws to give the
heat the lead
this is almost reminds me of as a kid
watching ali frazier
going into round 15 both guys
unbelievable